this is absolutely fascinating the right
wing Wall Street Journal
part of news corporation owned by Rupert
Murdoch has put out an op-ed
indicating that although Republicans
will be taking control of the house in
just a few weeks they are too dim-witted
essentially too stupid to wield power
this is super interesting not because
someone wrote Republicans are kind of
dim
most of us knew that but because the
right-wing editorial board of the Wall
Street Journal wrote it Republican party
masochists writes the editorial board on
uh Friday Republican Division and
disarray on Capitol Hill bowed ill for
the next Congress and the entire article
is worth reading but there's a
particular article that is interesting
um
I'll actually start with a paragraph
before their main demand is so
self-defeating talking about Republicans
here their main demand is so
self-defeating it could have come from
democratic congresswoman Alexandria
ocasio-cortez the dissenters want Kevin
McCarthy to concede that any member
could call the chair vacant and insist
on a vote to replace the sitting speaker
in order to get the votes to become
speaker McCarthy is supposed to weaken
himself so much that he wouldn't be able
to govern as Speaker yet a narrow
Republican majority of only 222 to 213
requires a leader who can enforce party
discipline that's how Nancy Pelosi has
been able to govern with the mirror
image majority in the last two years too
many House Republicans are too
dim-witted to understand the uses of
power and how to wield it they'd rather
Rage Against the Machine to no useful
effect
I don't care who wrote this and it
happens to be the right-wing Wall Street
Journal editorial board
it's completely correct and accurate as
an assessment of the Republican party
right now they are so obsessed with rage
and anger and fear that they care more
about perpetuating oh we're we're going
to take down McCarthy our Focus will be
to go after Hunter Biden or to impeach
Joe Biden even if we don't know why and
we're going to make people afraid of the
immigrants that Joe Biden's letting in
even though there's really no
significant changes to immigration
policy from Biden since Trump this is
what it's all about the rage is what
many of the modern Mega trumpists used
rage and fear to get elected in the
first place last week we talked about
reactionary populism many of them using
reactionary populism which includes
making people angry and making people
afraid that's why they don't have plans
or policies that's why they are totally
lacking in policy and a policy platform
Beyond just stop the Democrats from
doing uh what they want to do or what
they would like to do do they were the
angry opposition to what was happening
in power democrats for a while now
they're going to be in office they're
going to control the House of
Representatives the outrage is all that
they have and so that rage this is the
correct answer we've seen it for so long
now among these people and many of them
and I've spent time in parts of the
country where this is the case they grew
up in a church I spent time in rural
Northern or rural as some like to say I
don't say it that way rural Northern
Indiana and people basically go to two
places they go to church and they go to
a shooting range those are places where
you become angry and you become afraid
you're filled with hate rage and anger
and you see it firsthand in a lot of
these conservative places and they use
fear of immigrants members of the
Republican Party say it the dangerous
immigrants are going to come in you've
got to be afraid of them so we need
nativist immigration policy we certainly
need guns to protect ourselves from them
ignoring the reality
that both
uh naturalized
legal and undocumented immigrants both
are less likely to commit crime in the
United States than natural born citizens
and it makes sense if you know your
status is not legal or you have legal
status but you still see yourself as
someone who came here later you would
probably go out of your way to avoid
criminality and interactions with police
widely documented but yet fear of
immigrants it's in the church
is part of the narrative around why
people need guns grievances over
perceived injustices the right loves to
say it's the left that does grievance
politics actually it's the right it's
the right black lives matter movement is
bad and discriminatory and terrible and
we have a grievance against them and we
must fight them antifa
I could go on and on the the Free Speech
rights that are being taken away from us
which really aren't being taken away and
then of course the use of divisive
rhetoric for its own sake
um protect American values defend the
Constitution
defend and restore Free Speech things
that are meaningless if you follow the
facts on the ground but that they use to
drive these politics so I believe the
Wall Street editorial board is right
these Republicans will be taking control
of the house but they are too dim-witted
to really understand how to wield power
this is a good thing for the left to the
extent that they end up just chasing
their tails talking about Hunter Biden
for two years and hopefully
accomplishing nothing and maybe
Democrats can get a couple of things
done while Republicans are busy trying
to impeach Joe Biden